bueno tenemos un dato importante es la
tasa reproductiva de delta desde que de
cada caso podríamos tener hasta seis
casos más infectados y demi o entre uno
de cada caso positivo cuatro más
infectados digamos que o micro se está
comportando en medio de estas dos
variantes sin embargo hay que tener en
cuenta que este nuevo virus
aporta un cambio en su biología
principalmente dado porque presenta más
de 50 mutaciones y estas 52 mutaciones
están generando dos cambios principales
una vez en la proteína que se integra al
receptor en la célula respiratoria y el
segundo que es el cambio en esta
proximidad receptora está generando un
escape de los anticuerpos y está
generando en menos capacidad de
respuesta frente al mismo sin embargo lo
que sí estamos viendo es que
progresivamente aunque tiene una tasa de
reproductivo una tasa de infección mucho
más alta en los casos que están llevando
a la mortalidad y morbilidad no se están
representando con esta variante y a
diferencia de lo que estaba diciendo
efectivamente el director del agua meses
donde al tener ambas variantes
potencialmente lo que vamos a tener su
mayor número de casos de lucy y
potencialmente fallecidos por la cepa
delta que ayudándose de cierta manera
con la cebada
bueno sobre esa dupla le quería
preguntar porque esta semana científicos
sudafricanos publicaron otro estudio a
pequeña escala en relación o económica y
sus hallazgos sugieren que la infección
aumenta la respuesta inmune de las
personas y que esto podría proteger las
de delta usted qué opina
bueno estos estudios son muy
interesantes son preliminares pero se
basan principalmente en el mismo hecho
de que delta o micro comparte muchas de
las mutaciones tanto en la proteína s
como en otras unidades del genoma del
virus esto generaría que una vez
expuestos digamos los pacientes o las
personas tanto a la variante delta como
en la respuesta de los anticuerpos ya
sea por inmunidad adquirida o de unidad
innata y podría generar de cierta manera
es un alivio frente a las personas que
estén infectadas conjuntamente con
tratar y con tomic son en datos
preliminares pero es importante tener en
cuenta que eso no minimiza o no genera
una tranquilidad frente a la posibilidad
que tengamos muchas personas enfermas en
hospitalización y a la necesidad de que
mantengamos las políticas de vacunación
de manera intensiva en todo el mundo